on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on P Morgan on sens to prime
minister Rishi Sun pledges the UK's full
banking for Israel and says we want you
to win but as the world waits for the
Israeli ground offensive can it retain
international support I'll talk to ehu
Barak a former prime minister of Israel
and IDF General also tonight's streamer
Hassan ABI is one of the most influ IAL
commentators in the Pro Palestinian
movement online this week he said this
about me I would love to go on a show
and call him a baboon in a
suit well tonight he could do just that
because he'll be with
[Music]
me from the news building in London this
is pi Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to PE Morgan uncensored for all
the politics and tribalism that that
charges the debate about Israel's war
the one thing we should all be able to
agree on is surely that every innocent
life lost is a tragedy thousands of
people have been killed already all
leaving behind families or have to live
with unspeakable grief the difference
between the Hamas attacks and the
Israeli retribution is intent Israel may
be Cavalier about civilian deaths and to
use that awful phrase collateral damage
but killing civilians is not their aim
the Hamas Terrorist on the other hand
wanted to kill as many innocent people
as they could when it comes to blame and
condemnation that's an important
distinction when it comes to grief and
sympathy there's no difference and many
of our celebrities seem to forgotten
that to be clear actors musicians and
artists are under no obligation
whatsoever to air their views on
geopolitics they're perectly entitled to
it's a free country but I think we
probably all rather hear less of them
than more about these stuff but when
they do speak out they should try not to
let the gleaming intensity of their
virtue signal blind them to some basic
decency more than 2,000 British actors
including stars like Tilda swin Steve
cougan and Maxim Pike have signed an
open letter which condemns the war in
Gaza we're witnessing a crime and a
catastrophe they wrote Israel has
reduced much of Gaza to Rubble our
governments are not only tolerating war
crimes but aiding in abetting them we
demand that our governments end their
military and political support for
Israel's actions and on it goes not one
single word in this letter mentions the
Hamas Terror attacks not one single word
mentions the 14400 people in Israel who
were butchered nor were 200 men women
and children snatched as hostage
don't they care about them did they not
know that happened or do they think
perhaps that Jewish lives matter less
than Palestinian lives I don't know the
answer only they know that like so many
people in this crisis they've let their
political views get in the way of basic
perspective and human
decency another battle of the hearts and
Minds traditionally played out through
diplomacy and propaganda is being played
out online my next guest has almost half
a billion views for his provocative
commentary online making him hugely
influential asan P streams live under
the name Hassan Abby his analysis of the
Israel Hamas War has taken a highly
critical stance towards Israel and
Western media and he's been calling me
out for my coverage because he only
cares about Israel citizens he does not
care about Palestinians as human beings
that's why it's apples to oranges it's
like one side is a human the other side
is a barbaric monster child I never said
that obviously he says that he let
nothing more than to come on to unsent
call me a baboon in a suit to my face
well here I am a baboon uh and he can
join me now I'm joined by Hassan Hassan
thank you very much DAV coming
home thank you for having me Piers uh
it's very early here in Los Angeles
California but I'm going to try to do my
very best to to not do my British accent
while I'm here well I appreciate that
and listen I appreciate you coming on
explain to me why you consider me a
stenographer for the Israeli government
given that in the last week I think more
than any other host in the world I have
given lengthy platforms to Pro
Palestinian voices to articulate that
side of the
argument no I I I do have to commend you
uh you certainly have uh had more Pro
Palestinian voices than uh the rest of
the British media and certainly the rest
of Western media in general now as far
as uh saying that you're a stenographer
I said that journalists are not supposed
to be stenographers And yet when it
comes down to it in most circumstances
in whatever conflict uh we may be in
there are stenographers for whichever uh
whichever party is aligning with the
American state department and the
interests of the West in general and
Israel happens to be the one uh in this
in this ongoing conflict it's
interesting that you call me a
propagandist because I want to play you
this was your reaction to when the
hospital got I'm a propagandist for the
no no I'm not calling prop no no I'm
just saying I'm gon toay you say I'm
saying I am okay well then I want I'm
saying I am you even play it okay I'm
going to play the clip this is your
reaction to the bombing of the hospital
uh the other night while I was in the
process of of getting ready for the
stream uh Israel enacted uh one of the
singular worst strikes they have done
thus far and an air strike an Israeli
air strike hit the alah hospital in Gaza
City where thousands of civilians were
seeking medical treatment and Shelter
From the Relentless bombing campaign now
interestingly when that when you were
saying that uh I was coming on air too
and I took a position uh based probably
on 30 years of being a journalist
running major newspapers working at CNN
and others uh of waiting of just saying
I think we should just wait and see what
has actually happened here get
clarification
see who's actually to blame before we
start passing judgment you raced in to
assume as many people did by the way
including the New York Times BBC
mainstream media uh and of course most
of the Arab world uh Then followed that
this was clearly uh indisputably an
Israeli air strike or Miss hospital and
yet all the evidence now suggests very
strongly that it wasn't then in fact
this was a rocket that misfired coming
from a terrorist inside so my question
for you is this why would why would you
why would you be so certain in in what
you said before you
knew okay so first and foremost before
we get started on this conversation
let's understand something very
important here there's no electricity in
Gaza internet is patchy in Gaza there's
no food in Gaza there's no water in Gaza
this is all by Design This is because
Gaza is under a brutal blockade a brutal
occupation by the Israeli government
okay so that that plays a role in the
fog of war and misinformation that get
spread having said that however uh you
uh you made it seem as though there is a
certainty that this was uh 100% not an
Israeli air strike in I literally just
said I literally just said it's not a
certain okay sorry I said the evidence
the evidence is increasingly pointing to
this not being an Israeli air strike
and that is expert evidence from people
who have no skin in the game at
all Yes uh well I don't know which
expert you're you're talking about
because I think Channel 4 did a pretty
good job as a matter of fact I would say
Channel 4 did probably the best job so
far in analyzing everything that the IDF
has said but the reason why I believed
and I still do believe that the
likelihood is that this was an Israeli
bombing campaign wasn't only because of
the singular verifiable video the the
phone video from the balcony that uh had
all of the markings of an air strike the
fact that the Israeli Air Force was
enacting a bombing campaign in the
region at the time according to the AL
jaer live streaming footage that
everyone is using but doesn't understand
uh the fact that uh the the uh digital
media person uh for the IDF uh
immediately came out and and said that
this was actually a an air strike that
hit a Target and that he was sad that
there were you know uh casualties at the
end of the day but this this was a Hos
Target and celebrated it and more
importantly I guess the fact that this
hospital had been bombed by Israel this
hospital had been bombed by Israel on
Saturday 22 hospitals have as a matter
of fact been bombed by Israel since this
last uh Saga in the occupation and this
hospital had been bombed directly by
Israel where the Cancer Ward was
destroyed Israel has been bombing all of
these hospitals is is has been calling
all of these hospitals to evacuate over
and over and over again the medical
professionals at the hospital had been
called by the Israeli government uh the
day prior and everyone on the ground
assumes that this is an Israeli air
strike they are the ones who experienced
situation so when you have
you if you watch the BBC if you watch
the BBC account of all this last night
by their verify unit which was
specifically set up by the BBC to be
completely dispassionate in these
investigations and they reached a pretty
clear conclusion based on circumstantial
evidence I'll make that clear that this
would not have been an Israeli air
strike including for example the size of
the crater which Bears no relation to
the size of craters normally left by
Israel so look my point is neither of us
know for sure but you took to your
Airwaves immediately because actually
your I wouldn't even say unconscious
bias your admitted propagandist bias on
your part was that you wanted that to be
an Israeli air strike it suited your
narrative and I would say that that in
itself in its way being a stenographer
well you know you accuse me being a
sonographer I try and be fair and get to
the truth in your case I don't think you
try to do that I think you appeal to
your audience appeal to your base and
you don't really care whether the facts
are there or
not this is entirely unfair because you
just said circumstantial evidence favors
that this was not an Israeli air strike
I gave you all of the circum anal
evidence that does favor that this is an
Israeli air strike the reason why
however circumstantial evidence is not
enough and the one thing that I will
concede to because when more information
did come out and no I do not mean when
Israel said that they did not bomb this
hospital and it was actually Hamas and
then they turned around and went never
mind it's not Hamas it's actually
Islamic Jihad and then they said we have
more evidence coming out in a couple
hours and then the evidence came out and
it turns out it sounded like uh it it
the the phone conversations that they
were able to intercept supposedly uh
sounded like uh by experts at the very
least to be uh completely false and and
uh completely made
up Sy H I don't think even as you're
saying I think you're a smart guy let me
finish I think you've looked at all of
this and I think in your heart you know
this was probably not an Israeli air
strike and I'm just curious why you
would instead of admitting that as facts
change I'm saying that is not what I'm
saying I don't understand why you would
double and treble
down you're asking me to be on your show
do you want to talk yes if you're asking
me to be on your show and I want to be
on the show thank you so much for having
me on your show let me explain exactly
what I said and let me explain to you
why I think still to this very moment
until there is a thirdparty
investigation that is concluded by uh
the UN the international criminal court
or specifically a forensic analyst that
uh that looks at the situation is
allowed to be on the ground this is not
just my perspective this is BET selum as
well which is an Israeli organization
that has also demanded a third party
investigation occur I am not going to I
am not going to conclusively say that
this was not I fault I you because I
just gave you because I and not because
I'm a propagandist as far as me being a
propagandist goes everyone is a
propagandist I'm just honest about it
you're a propagandist we have our bi who
you think I'm a propagandist hon about
my bias who do you think I'm a
propagandist for
who do I think you're propagandist for
whichever your every every media person
is is doing propaganda this but who but
who for I've got to be doing it with
somebody you think it's a bad word I
don't that's just the difference this's
a it's actually quite a serious charge I
think it's a serious charge to level not
as a podcaster but as a journalist who's
broadcasting around the world who has a
reputation I believe for being fair and
impartial actually on these issues it's
quite a charge to just say I'm a
stenographer for the Israeli government
or I'm a propagandist I don't think
there's any evidence I'm either of those
things I'm curious who you think I'm
doing we're having this conversation
3,000 Piers while we're having this back
and forth
3,840 Palestinians have been ruthlessly
slaughtered in the last incursion into
Gaza I feel like this is an
incredibly selfish self-centered
conversation to have you asked me to be
on here you wanted you wanted to hear my
perspective I'm willing to give it to
you I don't want to talk about like
whether the I don't want to talk about
Nome Chomsky style manufacturing consent
conversations about how the media is
operating in the the the beest of theen
you the that there are dead people
listen H I only asked you because you're
the guy that called me a propagandist
and called me a baboon in the suit I was
curious as to why you don't want to say
who I'm doing the propaganda for we'll
move on we'll move on I agree with you I
there's a bigger there's a bigger
picture here let's move on let's take a
short break let's take a short break I
want to come back I want talk to you
about what happened on October the 7th
get your reaction to
[Music]
that
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back asan perer is still with me
asan I want to just play you a clip of
something that you said about the uh
October 7th Terror attacks and in
particular the attack at the music
festival which killed 260 people look at
this guy you know what shouldn't happen
killing 260 people at a music pestival
no you're right man that just happened
on its own cuz like bad guys wanted to
do bad things you're right dude if they
subjugated you to a open air prison your
whole life you're going to break out
eventually when you realize that there's
no other way to get out of it I mean it
sounds to me there
H that you are in some way saying they
had it coming were
you um no I wouldn't say that they had
it coming I think that uh Michael Brooks
used to say uh analysis is not
justification and while obviously
civilian casualties and and horrific
barbaric acts that were committed on
October 7 are completely
unacceptable uh the the important thing
to make sure that it never happens again
is to analyze what are the conditions as
to as to how it happened to begin with
and I think Barak is going to be on uh
in a little bit as well or maybe he's on
before me uh and and I'm and I'm almost
certain that while he has held the keys
to the conversation and held the the
levers of the power in this conversation
in many key and critical points uh I I
would go so far say that he is among
many others who also recognize that the
BB Netanyahu Administration is
responsible this is not just my
assessment this is uh 85% of the uh
Israeli population's assessment at the
time uh this is years and years and
years of refusing to negotiate with the
Palestinian Authority take don't take my
word for it take personal word for in a
closed door conversation with lud
members he said that if you want to
thwart any kind of Palestinian nation
state you must do everything you can to
only negotiate with Hamas we control how
high the how high the fire goes he's
given cash to Hamas by way of qar uh
there is no bigger fan of Hamas than
Biby Netanyahu which uh I hope one day
you can maybe uh interview and then
you'll ask him to no I I actually did
interview him a few months ago and I I
did actually spell out to him that there
were been a lot more Palestinian deaths
this year so far up to the point of the
interview than Israelis and what he
intended to do about it he said then he
didn't believe in Collective
responsibility which is now this hot
phrase in this whole uh crisis about
whether you would would hold all people
in Gaza responsible for Hamas
interesting to see if when they let me
just finish my point if they do they
launch a ground Invasion it' be
interesting to see if they keep to that
word you know I'm not a I'm not I'm not
a a defender of what bi Netanyahu has
been doing in Israel in the last year
his attack on The credibility and
integrity of the Supreme Court I think
it's been a disgrace and I think it has
fractured Society in Israel I also think
that it's caused so much social unrest
and had such big protests that you could
argue has taken the eye off the ball of
the people who should have been
defending the Border uh because they've
been trying to sort out what's been
going on domestically internally inside
Israel so I think it's a catastrophic
failure of intelligence of security of
Defense all of those things I'd be
amazed frankly if Nyah who survives this
so I'm certainly not here to defend him
even if you do view me as a stenographer
for his government uh my my question for
you I think is this is I've had a lot of
problems trying to get people on the pro
Palestinian side
to separate two things that you can say
as I believe and you believe that the
Palestinians have been maltreated for
decades that the situation where they
are effectively I mean I don't even call
it an occupation because Israelis aren't
in Gaza they pulled out in 2005 but they
still control the ability of Gaza this
is why I call you propaganda I'm just
saying the phraseology is confusing to
me because the reality is Israel
exercises control over people in G
it allows them in and out it allows them
to turn on the tap of water and so on
and so on I get all that they don't
actually live there because they can't
live side by side with each other that's
why it's called an open air prison right
I don't disagree they call the world's
largest open air pron h i don't disagree
with you and I've I've pointed this out
for a long time as a journalist so we
don't we don't disagree about the
appalling plight of Palestinian people
um but the issue comes that if you can't
separate that ongoing dispute between
Israel and Palestine from the absolutely
appalling barbarism of October the 7th
which was on a whole different scale to
anything we've seen where 1400
people Holocaust Survivors babies in
their in their cribs you know young
women taken uh tortured abused shot
beheaded with it was reported and so on
if we can't look at that collectively
with a with a a general humanity and
agreement that that is an absolute
atrocity then there's something wrong
with this and I find that the tribalism
on both sides is now so toxic and so
frenzied that you get people who
literally can't we've had a bunch of
actors right signing this statement
saying they want a ceasefire in Gaza and
calling Israel war criminals and so on
but they don't say a word about the
Hamas attacks that precipitated this and
I find that really really hard to accept
but but you but do you agree with them I
if if they had said for example that
October 7 attacks were brutal and and
massacres occurred and then they said
everything else that Israel is
committing war crimes would you agree
with them well okay here's what I would
honestly say about that is Israel not
allowed to defend itself from the worst
terror attack we've seen since 911 is it
not allow to defend itself after 1400
people in Israel are butchered that way
and the question then if you assume that
they are able to defend themselves as
any
the department line the line that is the
line that everyone let me ask you it
then becomes a question of how can they
defend themselves if their mission now
is to get rid of Hamas a terror
organization that's committed one of the
worst acts of Terror ever seen if that
is their stated aim then what they are
doing is consistent with that isn't
it no here's why this is actually an
abject failure and this is not just my
perspective on the matter I'm just a you
know dum dumb idiot with a twitch stream
who who is live reacting to the news and
trying to make sense of everything as
it's ongoing I usually have a policy of
not covering breaking news and and uh
sometimes that policy is violated but uh
ultimately I am not uh held up by the
same journalistic standards even though
I think I do a much better job than most
other news outlets in uh in general so
let me just say this really quickly you
said Israel has a right to defend itself
absolutely zero people think that this
is a ridiculous statement however how
Israel is defending itself is collective
punishment now Collective punishment in
the form of depriving 2.2 million people
of electricity Collective punishment in
the form of depriving them of of water
of food Collective punishment of uh in
the form of 51 people dying in the West
Bank where you know there is no Hamas in
the West Bank and yet 51 people have
died because in the West Bank settlers
that are occupying Palestinian territory
in violation of the international law
settlers who are doing an act of
colonial terrorism and this is not my
statement on it this is international
law that are doing horrifying things by
simply just existing there and and
maintaining the presence with a with an
occupying force in the form of IDF who
was ritualistically humiliating
Palestinians uh uh in in a in a
structure that Bellum an Israeli
organization calls the permit regime
where every waking moment of of uh
Palestinians lives in the West Bank are
absolute hell where they have no legal
recourse 51 Palestinians have died and
that was before the ramala uh the the
rala protest that happened last night
and uh the Israeli forces were uh
opening up with live fire on protesters
last night so who knows what that death
toll has become this is all this is all
a product of Israel being an apartheid
state this is a violent apartheid state
there is no way to be a peaceful ask
it is a violence violence required for
its maintenance and that violence is
frustrating people that violence is
radicalizing people as far as Israel as
far
as as far as what Benjamin Netanyahu has
done as far as the war government what
they have done Piers going into Gaza
yeah and bombing Gaza and killing
3,480 uh Palestinians so far in Gaza
1,000 plus children out of all of those
casual
22 hospitals being bombed a bakery the
only remaining intact Bakery being
bombed yesterday um these are these are
horrifying crimes that you would openly
say are horrifying and unjustifiable
when Russia does it but when Israel does
it it Israel has a right to defend
itself this is identical to the same
talking points that I've heard from
every Israeli Administration official
it's the same talking points that I've
heard from American politicians
championing the the exact same talking
points it's the same thing that I've
heard from everyone else in the media
you might have been against the Iraq uh
war and and you use that but you're
using that for for evil in my opinion at
this point if you are not sitting here
and condemning those acts of war crimes
those acts of violence that those acts
of collective punishment well I would
say to that that I think the death of
any child in this conflict is horrific
absolutely horrific but the question
comes down to me that after an act of
Terror as we saw on October the 7th
Israel should be able to defend itself
and should be a to go after the people
that perpetrated that who live amongst
civilians in in Gaza deliberately and
the question for me becomes down to what
is proportionate I don't know the answer
that I'll be honest with you I don't
know what that answer is I do know the
answer to that I do know the answer to
that last night I had uh Dr ofer kasif
uh an Israeli conent member who was
expelled uh suspended for 45 days for
saying uh what I believe is the truth uh
What uh championing the exact same
position of the the harat's editorial
board um there are a lot of thoughtful
people a lot of um uh formative
Holocaust Scholars a lot of historians
uh that all agree on the same point the
reason why violence that even penetrates
through the Israeli security blanket
that that people thought existed that
penetrated through that Iron Dome the
Iron Wall if you want to call it that is
because of years and years of Oppression
and years and years of violence which is
a necessity to maintain an apid State
and this has to stop there's only two
ways out of this either you engage in
full-blown ethnic cleansing and if you
if you listen to the likes of smotrich
or if you listen to the likes of itamar
B and these very unfavorable unpopular
far-right figures if you listen to
Netanyahu and his liud government uh
they say that they are interested in
going in that direction the ethnic
cleansing Direction the ethnic
displacement direction or the only way
out of this for a real solution is to to
move towards peace to genuinely have to
genuinely end the blockade to end the
apartheid to end the occupation and
create a pathway towards citizenship for
all people with a right to return for uh
all 14 million Palestinians uh uh 5
million of which live under Israeli
occupation it's brutal and then the rest
living in diaspora these are not
unreasonable requests these are requests
that understand the dignity and the
humanity of one side and does not simply
treat them as their their colonial
subjects and and it's the only way to
create permanent security and prosperity
in the region if it was as simple as
that I'm sure that would have happened
already I would say this I agree with a
lot of what you've just said not all of
it a lot of it I don't think you can
ever achieve peace now with Hamas
controlling Gaza I don't think you can
achieve peace with Netanyahu in charge
of Israel actually after I don't think
his own people will want him to be in
charge of Israel down Bel line when they
examine exactly how this happened but we
will see uh but Hass I got to leave it
there look it's good to talk to you you
know you're an important influential
voice to a lot of people um and I I
think we have a lot of common ground and
there are some things that we disagree
about but I suspect it's not as much as
you think you know I do think that the
core problem here has got to get
resolved in a way that's been completely
ignored for decades and until it gets
resolved until the plight of the
Palestinian people is resolved until all
these young people in Palestine feel
there's some sense of hope and they can
get out of what effectively is as you
say a prison camp then nothing is going
to change uh I don't think it justifies
in any to say I've got to finish it but
I don't think it justifies in any way
what happened on October the 7th but I
do agree with you that until that core
problem gets resolved there will never
be peace h i appre appreciate you
joining me thank you very
much thank you for having me on sus next
I'll be joined by the former prime
minister and IDF General ah Barack who's
been listening to that
[Music]
interview we're here good morning
everybody hope you're well thanks for
joining us you're watching the
independent republic of Mike gra right
here on talk TV welcome to Friday night
with Nadine here on prime time we like
to speak to the business people behind
big moments good evening I'm Pi Morgan
uncensored in New York City very
impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just stared
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella scon
[Music]
are you actually speech writing for this
she soon I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of booze up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy almost like paid Consultants
don't really know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem to have
given up welcome to the talk it's really
great to to be back my Little Darlings
kids think all they have to do is stay
at home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tock then
yeah problem
solved fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butcher dog him all
right but but he's now middle class us
here test the knock on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
now you're probably going to boot me off
show after
this got to say I'm not I'm not a Swift
critics I'd say me included got former
PMS all over the joint saying things the
last few we have indeed yeah great first
show you having fun oh a ton of fun King
PE and King Cube I think there's only
room for one king man you know what I'm
saying just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk when I say I am
God you think I'm joking or not you tell
me I'm not joking I'd rather do it on
camera no no if it's on camera we're not
doing an interview why we'll explain why
how do you feel about that influence
that you have you better be careful
we're coming for your children there
buddy about Maring Nation yes I'm going
to do you're going to Res yes cuz I
cannot continue my work it was a
fabulous dinner until you two uh mooned
us thank God for talk TV is not only the
home of common sense it's the only place
where you get the
[Music]
truth this is talk
TV
welcome back to on S I'm joined Now by
Israel's former prime minister ahu Barak
Mr Barack thank you very much indeed for
joining me I I greatly appreciate it I
want to start by playing you an extract
from an interview I did with u prime
minister Netanyahu back in March in the
middle of all the big social unrest in
Israel over his attempts to usurp the
power of the Supreme Court listen to
this we don't believe in Collective
punishment I go after the terrorists I
go after those who support the
terrorists but but I don't believe in
Collective punishment it seems to me
part of netanyahu's problem has been
that for political expediency he's had
to pack his cabinet full of very
hard-right people whose incend rhetoric
has done nothing but
fuel uh a lot of
Fury amongst the Palestinian people what
would you agree with
that you know the nomination of these
two racist
Messianic we call it in yish Michigan
else is a grave mistake of
netan there areia within the Israel
Society but it has nothing to do with
the crises we are now facing the um
Barbarian Massacre that happened in
October 7th started to be prepared
before Netanyahu government more than a
year ago before Netanyahu government was
ever established and it has nothing to
do whatsoever they are there are a huge
damage to Israel in one more than one
way but they are not the direct cause of
these event and these attacks when you
heard about the scale of what happened
on October the 7th how did that affect
you personally you've been a prime
minister of Israel you've been a general
in the Defense Force what was the
personal impact on
you look I I witness our people it was
the the most severe um blow that Israel
suffered in the since its establishment
we had never such an event well within
24 hours it's much more than 1400
probably we'll end up with 1,800 and um
several HS
were caught as hostages and they were
slaughtered slaughtered literally it's
not just a terror it's a crime against
humanity no one can remember such
pictures since probably Eastern Europe
during uh during World War II under the
Nazi ER Rule and that of course it
shocked the public but we are defiant
species we know how to unite when we
Face an external threat we are united we
mobilize over
300,000 reservist to make sure there is
enough Force to avoid any kind of a
further surprise and to be able to have
a major offensive in the G strip we got
support from the whole world the prime
minister sunak is now in Israel but
Biden was there yesterday aircraft
carrier is closing even some British
vessels and uh we enjoy a lot of support
and the third element which is very
important the you know in a way it's not
just a failure of the intelligent a
failure of the operational side and in
spite of heroic heroic response of the
soldiers on the ground it's still a
major failure of our defense system but
it's also a major fellow of the of the
political level and basically they they
lost the trust of the people and the
both the government and in a way the
military and a important step was the
creating some four days ago of a war
cabinet make made of Netanyahu and other
four people two of them were added from
the opposition leaders um gun and Eisen
they both are career generals before
they turn into politician both were
commanders of the Armed Forces of Israel
and both are very responsible
cool-headed balanced people so in a way
they're joining the war cabinet make
more citizen including myself more quiet
about the decisions that might come out
out H and translated by the Armed Forces
into action if this attack had happened
on your watch as prime minister would
you have
resigned I you know it depends to what
extent I would feel the situation I
don't want to answer it right now
because there is a the question of
course on the air in in regard to
Netanyahu I think that now we have to
focus first and foremost on response we
have to do something no modern State can
afford having it you mentioned earlier
911 you think in the terms of the
population like Americans having 911
with 50,000 people killed not
3500s so it's a major blow we have now
to focus we have to eradicate any
military capability of theas this is a
demanding enough Mr Mr BR let me just
jump in there because the Geneva
Convention Outlaws Collective punishment
uh prime minister Netanyahu when I
interviewed him back in March said he
did not he did not believe in Collective
punishment and he wouldn't exercise
Collective punishment in the way he
dealt with Palestinians but many would
argue including my previous guest Hassan
P that the fact that three and a half
thousand Palestinians have already been
killed in the last 10 days since October
the 7th does constitute a form of
collect punishment how do you go after
Hamas given that they are living amongst
the civilian population in Gaza without
exercising a collective punishment are
we not seeing that
now Israel is committed to the
interational law no Israeli Commander
ever get an order to a pilot to launch a
bomb on a hospital that's a crazy idea
and we can later on talk about it so we
are basically committed to it it's a
major constraint on our operation uh we
the right way is to warn everyone we
cannot afford not acting against the
Kamas so we announc on the first day
every one of you Gans who know that the
place where he lives or the place where
he works there is now or there was in
the past let's say to any Kamas activity
a launching pad for a rocket a lab a
munition or or weapons kind of a Depot a
kind of operational office or what or
trading site whatever you should leave
the place because we are going to hit it
and we said it once and again every day
some four days ago we announced all
gazans are asked to move to the southern
part of the Gaza STP in order to allow
us to hit the rest a half of million
moved another half million did not move
the Hamas deliberately used them as a a
human shield deliberately TR let me ask
from leing let me ask you this what is a
proportionate response 3 and a half
thousand Palestinians have already died
if there is a ground Invasion with
support from the air perhaps the sea as
well by Israel that number is going to
massively increase you're going to see
tens if not hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians killed here at what point
does it become disproportionate or
indeed as critics are already saying a
war
crime i h strongly believe that if
people will be focused enough to
understand that we are going to come we
are going to come with grand forces as
well because you cannot eliminate this
Barbarian Dash like or alqaeda like
groups that are slaughtering civilians
in our border I'm confident that if the
UK the Great Britain would have a 10,000
British ER citizens
slaughtered literally by a
dashik group O over your border that
jumped in you would take whatever steps
I don't want to go into history and
remind you of Dres and and other
operation I want to remind you that the
the UK as well as the United States H
sent its forces over half of the globe
in order to destroy Das these are H
enemies of H menkind and we have to get
rid of them now what happens take all
listen I agree with you but what happens
Mr Barrett what happen no you
cannot Pierce you cannot ask me why the
citizens of Gaza are not leaving the
places where we announce them days ahead
of time we are going to go there it will
be tough we will use fire because we had
to get rid of the physical let me let me
put it to you it may be because this is
their home these are their houses this
is where all their possessions are it
may be that they think to themselves why
should I leave my home I'm not
responsible for what have mass it why am
I going to face being K because of
it if you or or me would have faced the
choice whether to be killed as a result
of staying there or leaving it and stay
alive I would at least I'm know that I
would have lived and they have the right
to live they have the
opportunity let me ask you where where
are all these Palestinian people going
to end up where will they live will
their not not don't ask me how it will
end up once they leave they move to the
Souther par part of the Gaza Strip there
is enough place for them we are not
going to operate for 10 years it might
take several weeks or probably two
months if there are more people inside
it uh we will fight Hamas we will
eradicate their infrastructure and their
capability of repeat this crime Israel
cannot afford having Hamas attacking us
in this way again and I am confident
than any elected government of any
country on Earth would have done the
same and it's not inevitable that they
will killed on mass they can leave they
can leave now when we are speaking they
can leave tomorrow they can live next
day it it's not coming within few hours
but you cannot blame us for the fact
that Kamas coar people to stay as their
human shield you will end up with
impunity
to kind of Dash like terrorist because
they always can can in handgun hand some
Er people including the hostages I might
say as a kind of human shield for them
and that will paralyze Humanity from
being able
to struggle with is its more its worst
enemies and we are not going to stop to
stop it I'm confident that we'll we are
doing our best bet every Target is
checked more than once by different
teams to make sure that it's
legitimate Mr bar leave it there ex all
I would say is is the world is watching
and Israel has got to I believe in
Israel's right to defense but there's
going to be a Tipping Point if Israel is
not careful if too many Palestinian
civilians are slaughtered in Revenge for
what happened October the 7th the world
the world's mood will change and that
will be a dangerous moment for Israel
and for the world but listen we'll have
to see what happens and I
realize I want to
to I I have one one remark to me we
heard the same from the Americans even
without this advice which I fully
respect we are doing it any we fully
understand we have several constraints
on the operation one is the hostages the
the second is the risk that it will
spread to the north and become a
regional War the third one is the
question to whom we will pass the Tor
once we cleaned the the area from Kamas
we we are not going to stay there for we
need some player to take it let's think
of
Arab multinational force that take
responsibility for three three six
months and bring the original recognized
owner of the place which is the
Palestinian Authority or or any other
variation on this and the last H sincere
constraint is the international law we
fully understand that this Universal
support of Israel will erode as the
number of collateral damage which happen
to be a it's a kind of
vague definition it's basically people
who are innocent and are killed we don't
like to kill people who are innocent
understand we understand the
leg I have to I have to that I
understand that but this Collective
punishment issue if it looks more and
more like that is what is happening that
will be a breach of the Geneva
Convention so we're going to have to
wait and see uh how this all plays out I
Prim I have to leave it there I'm sorry
I do I do appr we w i we won't break the
Geneva Convention I would I would hope
that would not be the case uh Edward
barck I really appreciate you joining me
thank you very
much thank you on S next my P will be
with me uh for their response to those
interviews
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to S I'm joined Now by my P
Talk tov's international editor Isabelle
Oak talk TV contributor paulone Adrian I
want to play a clip this is King Charles
at the mansion house of the city of
London uh yesterday talking
about modern day discourse how we talk
to each other take a listen even in the
most fractious times when disagreements
are polished paraded and
asserted there is in our land a kind of
muscle
memory that it does not have to be like
this that the temptation to turn
ourselves into a shouting or
recriminating
Society must be resisted or at least
heavily mitigated whenever possible
especially in the digital sphere where
civilized debate too often gives way to
ranker you know it really struck a nerve
with me because I've been doing a lot of
pretty contentious interviews since
October the 7th and they've been getting
huge numbers of views online in
particular around the world on YouTube
10 million watch the Bassam youf
interview for example Ben Shapiro 6
million and so on but that's led to an
absolute Avalanche of abuse and threats
and everything else whatever you say
right because on both sides there are a
lot of extremists who will not tolerate
any deviation from their world view of
this yes and obviously it's historic
passions Run High the worldview is very
fractured about Israel and Palestine but
I thought Charles Hit the right tone
here Paula is that we've got to somehow
get back to being able to I've said this
a lot on the show to get back to
understanding that what Free Speech
means is respect and tolerance for
people's views even if you really
disagree with them and a responsibility
for yourself in terms of what you are
saying so if you're advocating free
speech then by all means remember that
you also have a responsibility don't you
in terms of what it is that you want to
communicate to the other person I think
King Charles absolutely nailed it and
it's what was needed because quite
frankly we're not getting that from our
politicians
we're not getting that from our prime
minister I mean sometimes the sheer
volume of it just absolutely takes your
breath away doesn't it I mean when
you're in the public eye as you are and
I am to a lesser extent you grow used to
the kind of base level of viciousness
and unpleasantness and always the
attribution of the wrong motives you
know the imping of one's Integrity
whatever one is saying or whatever point
is being argued it's always it must be
about your private well I had a guess
earlier saying that I was a propagandist
for the Israeli government when I
actually told him well who am I doing
the propaganda for he didn't actually
want to say that again because he knows
that's ridiculous obviously I'm not and
the questioning of all people in the
last 10 days would show that but I I've
been struck by people taking clips from
interviews that I've done with whoever
it may be Bassam USF or the Palestinian
Ambassador whoever it is taking clips
and then deliberately twisting the
meaning of those Cs and putting that out
as fact and them getting 10 million
views for what is a lie calling me a
liar I mean it's quite shocking and I'm
not quite sure how you stop it it's
really really difficult as you push back
and they'll clip that and distort it
again and it and it's been hugely
important already in this conflict I was
just looking at some figures uh more
than 40,000 fake accounts promoting Pro
Hamas narratives and Ordinary People
quite understandably it's hard enough
for those of us that have supposedly got
some expertise find it very very hard to
distinguish some of this stuff lots of
journalists who are just not putting
their head over the paret this they
don't want to face the blowback I get it
you know I'm not in that position I'm a
strident person by Nature I call things
as I see them I don't come at things
from a partisan position and you have to
do it but M it's important that you
continue to do that full it is
absolutely important that you continue
to do that and I appreciate that this is
slightly Sid stepping but we see what
happens to presenters whose lives have
been threatened whose lives have been
lost because they have dared to to speak
out or act in a way that that whatever
for whatever reason a member of public
didn't didn't like you have got to keep
doing that because if you don't then
others will be too fearful and that
you're seeing that already we've got to
leave it there uh thank you both very
much indeed I appreciate it that's it
for me next week we'll be live from New
York whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good
[Music]
night
we're here good morning everybody hope
you well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just sred out
at me and you conquer time who wins you
do you know what I love about toour
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose l
stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you you we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing label would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem to have
given up welcome to the talk it's really
great to be back my Little Darlings kids
think all they have to do is stay at
home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem problem solved
fit as a butcher's dog there you go he's
fit as a butcher's dog him